hi this is spencer ackerman with wired
com in the flight deck control of the
USS Wasp amphibious assault ship off the
Atlantic coast and i'm here with
lieutenant Andrea Albert she's the
aircraft handling officer for the wasp
and lieutenant with him it smashes she's
known smash tell us how to take off and
land a helicopter on one of your very
busy days on this very busy deck well
everything starts out in the morning
with flight quarters being set and we do
a fog walk down that stands for foreign
object damage to make sure there's no
nails or bobby pins anything on that
flight deck that could get blown as the
booty and hurt someone or he sucked into
an intake and we set up and flight deck
control here do a comms check with the
tower with everyone out and flight deck
who has communications with us and a lot
of background checks the aircraft will
call into the tower we have people are
getting my leg over once i clear them to
land the flight deck who will direct the
helicopter over the spot and land it and
what kind of aircraft you have here on
the lusca while we were able to launch
the av-8b harrier sh 60 Seahawk witches
are usually the search and rescue
aircraft it's going to be the first one
launched and the last one recovered the
ah-1 Cobra which is an attack helicopter
uh-1 huey which is an all-purpose
helicopter in the mv-22 Osprey the tilt
rotor is able to fly in a helicopter and
fixed-wing front of the road walk us
through some of the complexities in
getting these things on and off and more
or less the same time in kind of choppy
weather like today ok well we have an
ideal time line and everything is going
to take off so we're always gearing
toward that the ship has to be set up
correctly to have the winds
in the right envelope the air crew has
to be ready the passengers loaded on the
helicopter we have a combat cargo team
the landing signal and listed as the
gentleman or lady who directs the
helicopter on the flight deck tells it
when to lift and directs it we have
chalk and chain personnel who run in and
take out the big heavy chains that hold
the helicopter down and once it's ready
to go the tower will be of clearance for
the LOC to lift the helicopter and off
it goes
you